[Music]
for the first time in recent history the
u.s. arrested a Chinese intelligence
officer this week and brought him to
America to face charges
eunjin Xu is accused of stealing
intellectual property and trade secrets
from u.s. aviation and aerospace
companies a report from the US Trade
Representative says China's economic
espionage costs the u.s. between 225 and
600 billion dollars a year john carlin
helped bring the first-ever charges
against Chinese hackers he co-authored a
new book called dawn of the code war
carlins served as assistant attorney
general for national security in the
Obama administration welcome John
morning ok put this this arrest in
perspective here of young Jin Xiu the
look it's one of the first times ever if
not the first time that you've been able
to catch one of the puppet masters from
overseas in China who's running
intelligence operatives inside the
United States day in day out and
stealing secrets so for an American this
would be like if one of our CIA agents
got busted in some other country and was
brought to trial is that the equivalent
essentially and they cleverly got him to
leave China they almost never leave
China into a third country where he'd be
subject to arrest and it shows that this
new strategy it's not just bringing
charges to name and shame and layout the
theft that's happening of American
intellectual property it's that their
real charges and that people face real
consequences including jail cells give
us a sense of so there's intellectual
property theft
there's meddling and elections give us a
sense of the whole smorgasbord of
threats here yeah one of the reasons I
wrote the book is that there are so many
instances that people think are science
fiction that have already happened
including terrorists stealing from
retail companies personally identifiable
information of customers in order to
have plots to kill them including
Chinese espionage that's driven
companies into bankruptcy costing real
jobs inside America and most troubling
is that the next time we get into a
military conflict are very fighter jets
with our research and development that
spent years in the
making could be used against us to kill
our servicemen and when it comes to
cyber warfare a lot of focus has been on
Russia and rightly so but FBI director
Christopher Rea just this week said
Russia is fighting today's fight China
is fighting tomorrow's fight the next
day and the day after it's you right
that's one of the things so you think
about our economy and our military and
even our electrical grid the electricity
that we have before us it is all
dependent now on digital technology we
moved almost everything we value from
books and paper to digital over a
25-year period and we did so while
discounting risk China in particular
along with Russia North Korea and Iran
recognized that vulnerability and
they're hitting us day in day out we are
in a code war now and to direct a raise
point what we're seeing is when it comes
to next-generation technology artificial
intelligence the way all of our phones
connect wirelessly that China is getting
the lead and they're doing it not by
playing fair not by investing in
research and development but by stealing
it and using our own technological
know-how against us are we doing enough
to combat it No
so I think and partly it's because it's
reason I wrote the book is that people
don't realize today how vulnerable we
are when I go out to talk to businesses
they're surprised by the inside story of
cases that we've already brought and
these are all cases that we successfully
figured out who did it we're much better
that than people think the problem is
after we bring these cases after you
call out China after you call out Russia
for not Pecha which caused billions of
dollars of damage to companies around
the world
there's no follow-on consequence that
forces them to change behavior so it
sounds like we're not winning the code
war and I just want to quote from a new
government report that found almost all
of the u.s. military's newly developed
weapon systems have quote
mission-critical
cyber vulnerabilities so why has the
government so far failed to protect our
defense systems well partly we need to I
think for a long time we thought there
was a technical fix where you know you
do it right and you're safe and that
doesn't exist the technology that we're
basing this on the internet itself uses
a protocol that was never designed with
security
in mind we can do better and we need to
right now to your point is is that
devices our cars the peacemakers in our
hearts are now using that same
technology we can't make the same
mistake that allowed our Social Security
numbers to get stolen to cause actual
life-and-death consequences and there
are actions that we can take we should
be looking at our phones and some of our
devices a bit differently thank you so
much for talking about this very
important subject Thank You hate it and
Donna the code Wars goes on sale October
16th